one chance ball throw one ball one will
[Music]
[ __ ] didn't even get to die I am fail
yeah failure is just another way for
victory
oh no no helm a douche got away push it
my saw your sacrifice made me live yeah
lady no you help please help anybody
please can i grab on to somebody oh god
I thought I was in danger for a second
there Oh mega poon run you stole my
heart and crusher
you one more death I'm gonna get this
yeah
oh now I'm more aerodynamic oh oh
you can't just I'm just lost what am I
gonna do I have no proper size there are
new time codes doesn't I go and cut our
say our present a gun what's up Cole up
morass we don't hurry up hair down [ __ ]
death ball I like me some death ball ha
ha huh might fall down piss you put me
down
I was made it
all right kids we're gonna good this
time coin wherever here ha ha
this seems like an insurmountable
challenge for one the level chimney that
Santa cannot fit in Santa Troy well time
for my reward crazed 999.9 nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein oh that's with
failure suck on that
suck on that double kill whatever to you
that doesn't seem right
but oh ah ha oh the deserts are too bad
hot ha Justin Bieber you're the left one
nailed every single one on the first try
cuz I am incredible I'm Santa
oh damn right I'm coming honey let's
talk about Fred I know my legs
nah Sarah flex your tush that I've been
robbed I heard every go come here fat
ass I faked out oh god no I'm not with
but ha ha ha no one saw anything nothing
happened
certainly wasn't porn jump quickly press
see ah ha ha ha missed me this time ha
ha good thing that you are not uh-huh in
my head I suppose I'm still alive and
demeanor afraid of water
ha ha ha ha I am lack lax belt you give
villagers you give them what's over
there what is this star car star car ah
don't shoot arrows up my ass minds can't
hurt you but heart ah that was a lie oh
the dirty dirty lie
good luck you'll need it
kid you didn't know my name is marooned
oh no oh hey so bad look at me go
you think I need luck 101% impossible
[Music]
like everything I do
Hey here we go I'm a launch you and
you're gonna make it to the eggs okay
we're done I did not go according to
plan
oh I can get what I wanted for my down
nine nine nine nine nine or 99.99%
impossible first right oh you didn't see
anything except all that raining blood
Oh what did I hit ah oh oh okay this one
actually might be a little bit hard Wow
miss me Oh with that ah oh whoops
Huh What huh what are doing
Oh No Wow my my unicorn horn is so long
[ __ ] all that Oh dah
Oh the themes almost cruel no no one
like this show or everyone likes a show
how do you guys want me to think I'm
easy to please this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you like with the Sun you want to see
more why not subscribe to my channel
want to help the channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites
write a comment below or share it with
your friends on Facebook thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]